Oh welcome to this video playing the
Rainmaker Rainmaker that's Olaf zepa
right Olaf zip I played him from more
than 20 25 maybe with our accounts may
be without would have come and played
him a lot with white I remember double
Fiat Cheetos and here are also called
for double fianchetto wanted to try that
opening rookie 1 i'm going to block you
for from the get-go race he wants to go
your form and double he will he will
play it i mean i have no way to prevent
it yeah this is a bit test some limbs Oh
Indian some limbs onion flare this kind
of position
I wonder maybe I should have taken on
the form and anyway interesting an
interesting position and i know i will
take definitely making sure that the see
file opens up so Bishop a six I guess
oopsie one and then I on you five if I
us normal do I have something better
don't have a check check on some kind of
tactic and I don't think so but if I've
is good increasing the pressure there a
little bit maybe if I mean maybe I can
provoke the 527 would have been
interesting though for cone a phone okay
he did play that and out for Queen a for
now yeah some experience in the limbs Oh
does help in this position and this is
quite a common thing actually if you
know the names of Indiana it will help
you in many other openings because it's
such a great school in strategic chest
this opening so he is allowing the Queen
trajan I'm doing this and now have five
maybe a fire for
I it's got it for himself no you didn't
do that interesting okay let's push our
phone and what happens now push-up age 6
now let's prepare that I wanted to make
sure that you can also easily go G for
this is why I went age five I wonder if
no one I'd be three it's not working now
because I can take one g3 and super solo
q 7i guess check okay you got Angie form
but now this vicious kind of stuck on e6
hmm
okay it's not so bad I can do this him
and W on the sea phone
slap that pressure against you for it
really does not much change even though
that light square Bishop trade isn't
ideal one thatís you really have
something else there than taking I can
maybe age three or something I that said
said certainly move or not be three
maybe not be three is interesting maybe
this one okay I'm not going to hesitate
here for long no this first or not
whoo-hoo I don't know maybe this yeah be
five you always at c5 ok I have to
reconsider their go for the H file now
going back here or yeah I guess and o
gauge to my have to activate iam so
maybe he will lose this I can add with
this though
the thing is I should should try plenty
three now this Andrew h8 h 3 this is
more interesting kicking with the pawn I
guess 7 a-4 sorry for that's for those
sounds really i don't know why and I try
to fix it but it didn't really work so
let's do this and see maybe c5 is a move
now my idea is a phone and no this one
time warning
I'm done on time didn't really saw that
didn't really see that you keep this for
the moment trip a 7 I can then take and
I'm threatening bishop in six year well
who it's got 96 check in the in the mix
somehow 95 is not working why not [ __ ]
am I wasn't I'm not I wasn't totally
sure why it might not work no I'm
threatening c4 check and rook f2 and
then C for both the strong
okay you don't have much time I can
actually take a five and maybe maybe
could have taken not entirely sure mmm
my position is kind of on a moon yes
really and says some way to improve on
that maybe like this and whoops didn't
see that one but maybe is not c4 oh what
a bad blunder past him no I don't give
me that nonsense I'm losing this game oh
no aah wow that was a complete win
actually okay try 500 did I screw this
one up it was so nice here I mean that's
not never working here so C 4
immediately does win see form and then
there should be six wins the home button
has to take here here and I resins added
that couldn't work I mean it really
couldn't but this isn't that easy it
really isn't that easy my pawns are so
bad and I don't really have a clear way
to to do this Mandy I'm winning again an
IP 524 why didn't I do that that is a
stupid move a really stupid move
I played that terribly badly this whole
thing I mean have two pawns up I mean
it's not easy or so but this is easy
actually just going there pick up
everything and it was completely mmm in
some dire straits here anyway yeah I
didn't find the right way really and
this then he allowed me this Bishop d8
stuff well this is not working again and
now it's stupid loss really stupid loss
okay thanks for watching